سنتابع الان الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل
من جنين بحسب مراسله الجزيره استشهاد سته
شبان فلسطينيين في قصف مسيره اسرائيليه
لمدخل جنين الجنوبي شمال الضفه الغربيه
كنا قد عرضنا قبل قليل ايضا صورا وردت قبل
قليل وهذه صور
جديده تظهر الصور ايضا اعطاب اليه
اسرائيليه نذكر مره اخرى بالخبر العاجل
الذي نقلته مراسله الج ز وهو استشهاد سته
شبان فلسطينيين في قصف مسيره اسرائيليه
لمدخل الجنين الجنوبي شمال الضفه
[موسيقى]
الغربيه
وف
[موسيقى]
الان بالعوده الى الاحداث في اسرائيل ولا
سما الخلافات السياسيه مؤخرا ينضم لنا من
تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره محمد خيري محمد هل
نحن اولا ازاءه
تعاظم حاله المطالبه باستقاله او اقاله
بنيامين نتنياهو في الشارع
الاسرائيلي نعم نشوان بدايه دعني اقول ان
بما يتعلق في الجنين الموضوع الذي تناولته
قبل قليل الان اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
اربعه جنود اصيبوا في
جنين منهما باصابات خطيره وواحد باصابه
متوسطه وواحد باصابه خفيفه كما قال جراء
انفجار عبوه ناسفه وقال انه استهدف خليه
زرعت هذه العبوه بالقصف